ils se sont installés dans une galerie
commerciale des drapeaux européens des
stands pour expliquer les fonds de
l'union européenne et un quizz pour
tenter de gagner un week-end dans une
capitale européenne l'europe objet
politique pour beaucoup non identifié
est très vague s'est rapproché des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
souvent les citoyens sont peu informés
des actions sont financés par l'europe
est une grosse part des fonds social
européen sur le territoire qui est
consacré au retour à l'emploi
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la rénovation énergétique
de logements mais aussi des associations
locales au service des plus fragiles les
ponts ropéen finance de nombreux projets
sur le territoire
une découverte pour les passants c'est
assez par eva et comme si toujours
curieuse passé et j'ai du coup je me
renseigne
quand les petits jeunes et ou qui vont
passer dans l'après midi c'est très bien
ça va les inspire l'opération séduction
et communication du joli mois de
l'europe se poursuit en juin sur toute
l'île de france
l'association peut que mu proposera
installé sur un transat l'expérience
d'un concert jardine halles à paris le 9
juin et dans les yvelines à la fin du
mois le 13 juin les porteurs de projets
et curieux sont invités à découvrir les
locaux de l'atelier un centre d'affaires
en seine et marne